they're definitely hiding something
alex be careful
when i moved to haven springs i hadn't
seen my brother gabe in years
alex it's just so good to see you again
welcome to haven this place is pretty
sweet
i'm glad you two met is this dude my
best friend and this dude
hands me the best beers alex right
i'm stuff i didn't realize that we all
knew you were coming
for the first time in years well what do
you think
i love it i really let myself believe
welcome home i don't know what to
believe now
except gabe is dead
this one's for you gabe
[Music]
hearing everyone talk about my brother
[Music]
about the life he had here with all of
you
i lost the chance to have that
what happened to gabe was a senseless
tragic accident
it wasn't an accident son now is not the
time
alex are you okay
no they're definitely hiding something
what happened here haven't's a community
we help each other
there's something you should know about
me
[Music]
i know what other people are feeling i
can see these
auras around them
if they're angry or sad or afraid i feel
it too
when i focus i can even understand why
they're feeling it
and if somebody's feeling something big
it infects me
and i lose control
[Music]
i've never told anyone
but now i can find out what's really
going on you'll need help
i've got your back
you